Tom,
welcome to Google.
Thanks for having me,
man.
I'm excited to be here.
Yeah,
it's,
it is our pleasure.
So I'm,
as I mentioned before,
we got going where we're very big fancy of quest nutrition.
Yes.
That's exciting smores.
Is that the flavor of the day?
And I can't wait for Thursday,
which is cookies and cream.
There you go.
All right.
Those are two heavy hitters,
man.
Respect on the choice.
Well,
thank you facilities.
Um,
so,
so Tom,
you have a wonderful story.
Very fascinating and resume if I do say so.
And I'm,
so let's start from,
from there.
You,
you majored in film at USC,
then you went into technology,
right?
Obviously,
obviously.
And then you went into nutrition hat.
Can you kind of walk us through sort of that,
um,
that road that you took?
Yeah,
there were a lot of changes that I'm having in my life that made those things
happen.
So in film school,
a USC film school is statistically speaking harder to get into than Harvard law.
And I had managed to get into USC film.
I was thinking,
Hey,
I'm the business over here.
Like,
I'm just going to crush it.
And the first year I did and I did very,
very well.
And that set me up in my final year at USC to be able to do a thesis film and
only four people in the entire class get to do a thesis film.
And I was chosen as one of them.
So I went from no one thinking I'm going to be able to get into film school.
The career counselors at USC literally told me to stop taking film classes cause
they're like,
you're not going to get in.
We see this happen all the time.
People think they're going to get in.
They don't.
And so I said,
look,
I'm going to take somebody out from the admissions committee and just pin them
down and say,
what do I need to do to get in?
So I did that.
I took one of the guys out and I said,
um,
my sats,
I got a nine 90 on my sats and I took it twice.
And I'm saying that here in Google.
So I know you guys got some real sat scores,
which I did not.
And so the,
the counselors are looking at my sat scores and saying,
this isn't going to happen.
I'm sitting down with the,
one of the guys in the admissions committee said,
look,
those are my sat scores.
What do I need to do to get in?
And he said,
look,
we accept people at two phases.
One is an incoming freshmen and then your sat scores matter a lot.
And then as an incoming junior and your sat scores don't matter at all because
they're meant to just tell me how well are you going to do in school.
But by then you'll have had two years here at USC.
I'll just look at your grades.
So I'm a freshman at this time.
So he said,
look,
just if you get grades that are good enough,
I'm not even going to look at your sat scores.
So I took that is like,
that's my mission.
So I went and locked myself in a dorm room for two years.
I didn't date,
I didn't party at and drink,
do drugs,
nothing.
I worked and I studied and that was it.
And so I ended up getting into film school.
So get into film school,
then I do well in film school,
get the senior thesis film and I think this is that I'm unlock,
I'm going to crush the senior thesis film.
I'm going to get out,
I'm going to have the three picture deal.
I'm going to go take over.
Hollywood's going to be amazing.
I'm going to be,
you know,
rich and famous by the time I'm 26.
And that's that like,
right?
Like it's all true.
And then,
uh,
I failed so miserably on my senior thesis film so publicly and so embarrassingly
that it,
it absolutely destroyed my sense of self.
And so as I'm crashing and burning and cause it's,
it's pretty dog eat dog in the film industry in Los Angeles in that little
microcosm of film school.
And so people are laughing,
excuse me,
laughing about how poorly the film went and all that stuff.
And so that's how you failed in regards to like the reception that film
received.
Yeah,
it really was bad.
There's just no two ways about that.
Like even if people have been like,
oh,
Tom,
you tried so hard.
Like it just was a bad film.
It was so bad in fact that I stole the master film so that can never be watched
again.
I want to be really clear about how truly valid the sun was.
And so in that moment I realize,
and it's funny how often people push back.
What I realized was I did not have talent as a filmmaker and that's such a
deeply uncomfortable thing for people to say or to here.
And it was for me at the time for sure.
And it's not for me now at all because now I don't worry about innate talent.
I only worry about a growth mindset,
being able to get good at something.
And so,
excuse me,
I'm dealing with a coffee here.
Um,
if I had understood at that time that I could get better,
it wouldn't have created the panic,
but I didn't think I could get better.
So that was the first movement.
Then once I leave film school,
I'm totally lost.
I realize I'm a talentless hack.
I don't know what I'm going to do with my life anymore.
I decide that I'm the only path for me is going to be to become the king of
remedial jobs.
And I wanted it to feel good about myself.
And so I was going into positions where I'd be interviewing where I knew I'd be
smarter than the person interviewing me.
And
the likelihood of the job,
me getting the job was virtually 100% and so that was where I was and I was
selling video games,
retail.
And I mean this is after getting a degree and having tens of thousands of
dollars in student loan debt,
I'm working in these really dead end jobs,
just trying to make ends meet and trying to figure out what I'm going to do with
my life.
So you purposely aimed lower.
I literally purposely aim lower and it was an ego boost and it was great.
And then luckily somebody offered me a job teaching at a film school and I
thought,
okay,
well those that can do and those that can't teach,
so this is,
this is perfect.
And I start teaching and I realized,
Whoa,
like I'm,
I'm embarrassing myself in front of the class.
I,
oddly enough actually don't know enough to be teaching this.
So I'm going to have to go home at night and learn
enough in the lesson
to be able to come in the next day and teach.
But then as I start doing that,
I actually started improving.
And so I start thinking,
well,
if I can make my own films better or can I help them make their films better and
if I can kind of make my own better.
So at this point you're well like two,
two years removed from school.
What timeframe?
We're looking from USC.
Yeah.
So it had exactly that.
About two years out.
And so you're teaching,
you're kind of,
you know,
touching up on your own career,
I suppose as a filmmaker.
And then how did that lead into oh wait,
nutrition
that,
so we now we have to cross the chasm between be considering myself,
the king of remedial jobs,
then realizing that I can help these people make their films better.
And by the transitive property I should be able to make my films better.
So that is the beginning of me really thinking about a growth mindset.
Which up until that point,
I had never had a growth mindset and Carol Dweck had not yet written her seminal
book growth mindset on the topic.
So
Nick,
can you explain a little bit about the differences between like that growth
mindset and the fixed mindset?
Yeah,
definitely.
So a fixed mindset,
somebody that has a fixed mindset believes that their talent and intelligence
are fixed traits,
that whatever you're born with,
that's it.
Those are going to be,
that's as good as you're ever going to be.
And so,
hey,
make the most of it.
Somebody that has a growth mindset realizes that that's just your starting off
point.
And while we may not all be equal from where our starting off point is,
the human animal is literally designed from the ground up to be able to adapt.
And so it begins to be a question of how much are you willing to adapt?
What price are you willing to pay to get great at something?
And so teaching,
I'm determined to survive this interview here.
Teaching was the first thing that really began to give me that sense that,
okay,
wait a second.
I could put time into this,
I could learn,
I could grow,
I could get better.
And while I'm teaching,
these two guys come in and they see me teaching and they were very successful
entrepreneurs and ironically they were bodybuilders.
Now as a kid growing up,
I had promised myself two things.
So growing up in Tacoma,
a slightly chubby kid in a morbidly obese family,
that teeter between blue collar and white collar.
I'd promise myself,
one day I'll be rich and one day I'll have six pack abs.
And so these two guys walk in,
they're rich and they have six pack abs.
And they were like,
Hey,
you're pretty bright.
We're about to start this company.
We need a copywriter.
Why don't you come be a copywriter for us?
But don't think of yourself as a copywriter.
Understand that you can have any role that you want in this company.
You just have to become the right person for the job.
And so I was just young enough and just hungry enough to,
you know,
really transformed my life and make of it that I leapt at the chance.
I left my teaching position,
I went out,
started working with them,
and through that process of building that company,
and this is a very long story that I think is,
is powerful and interesting,
but I'll spare you so that we can cover some other topics,
but it ends with me having an emotional crisis and to really
the first emotional crisis is I'm arguing for things that I know are worth for
the company,
which means that they're less likely to make me rich,
but because they were my idea.
So I'm fighting tooth and nail for an idea that I know is wrong,
that I know will move the company backwards,
that I have a voice in my head screaming,
you know,
this isn't going to work,
but I so want to be right.
I so needed to be right that I keep pushing and I keep arguing.
And then finally one day,
because my partners were much smarter than I am,
they just and all define intellect is the ability to process raw data rapidly.
So they could just process raw data very fast.
They could think through the situation faster than I could
because of that.
I was always feeling badly about myself because I just could not think them.
And because at that point I had a fixed mindset and I valued myself and being
right,
good,
smart,
worthy,
right?
All permanent states of being because someone with a fixed mindset believes
everything is a permanent state of being.
So I needed to win this argument and ironically
I ended up winning the argument to my detriment and realize,
okay,
now what?
And I have this moment of crisis where I'm like,
I always tell people what I really want in life is to be rich.
But I'm acting as if what I really want is to just feel good about myself on a
neurochemical level.
So in a way you find it for this idea that you knew was wrong,
was kind of a good way of a certain control over the situation.
It was my way of being,
right?
And because I valued that and my self esteem was built around being smart and
being right.
If I was around people who were smarter than me and I was always wrong,
then I had no self esteem.
And so
I literally then end up asking myself that very question,
which is just be honest about what you want.
Like if what you want is to feel good about yourself,
then you need to leave this environment because you don't feel good around these
people that are smarter than you.
They've got more good ideas than you,
so leave.
But if on the other hand,
what you really want is your goal,
you actually want to get rich,
which was my obsession at the time,
then you've got to figure out another way to think about your self esteem.
And that's what I did.
Okay,
so in that moment I realized I needed to switch what I built my self esteem
around to something that is antifragile.
Now,
at the time I didn't have the words antifragile.
If you guys have and seem to labs book by that name,
then you know what he means.
Something that resilient or strong or tough,
they're still all defined by their breaking point,
but something that's antifragile actually gets stronger the more you attack it.
And so I was trying to think of what is something that's going to make me feel
better about myself?
The more I realize I'm wrong,
the more I realize that I'm stupid,
not the smartest person had the worst idea that I'm not yet good enough.
All those things like how do I make that,
not a liability,
but my very strength,
the very thing that's driving me.
And that became flipping what I built my self esteem around to building it
around,
identifying the right answer faster than anyone else.
Always being willing to admit when I was wrong and actually taking pride in
that.
So that in a business meeting,
if 30 seconds before I had been arguing tooth and nail about an idea,
it's mine,
I believe in it.
I'm going after it.
And then somebody says something and I realized they're right.
Then on a dime I would stop and say,
you've got the right answer.
And then I would become the energy behind that idea.
And that was the first real crisis of readjusting sort of your expectation
around your self esteem and your values.
100% and as soon as I made that switch,
I started moving up in the company very,
very quickly.
So,
okay,
now flash forward a few years I become an owner in the company through sweat
equity.
The company is worth at the height.
I think it was valued at like $22 million.
So on paper,
I'm a multimillionaire.
My salary's higher than it's ever been in my life and now I'm completely
miserable.
And I'm like,
I'm living the cliche of money,
can't buy happiness.
And I'm like,
this is a joke.
Like this was so predictable and so easy to see coming.
How have I actually gotten caught in this trap?
And I began to realize that I wasn't pursuing things that gave me more energy.
I was pursuing something that was taking more energy than it was giving.
I wasn't pursuing something that I was passionate about.
Okay?
And what I didn't yet understand about money is that money is in and of itself.
It's a nerve,
right?
Nobody's safe for maybe Scrooge MCDUCK and possibly Warren buffet like would
actually get off on swimming in their own money.
Right?
So it's not the money,
right.
When you talk to Warren Buffet,
part of what drives him is it's a scorecard,
right?
And he gets off on the scorecard.
But if you don't,
if that's not your thing and it's not mine.
So I'm building this business,
I'm learning all these skills.
I'm coming in,
I'm working my ass off,
I'm working seven days a week,
I'm not taking days off.
I'm damaging my relationship at home and all for what money.
Now,
the vast majority of my wealth at the time was tied up in the equity of the
company,
which basically means you have none,
right?
So most people don't even understand the difference between paper money in
liquid cash.
Paper money is not interesting.
Like they'll write about it in Forbes magazine and kids will come up to me
freaking out because they know my net worth is crazy high.
And I'm like,
the only thing you should care about is how much money do I have where I can go
now manifest something in the real world,
build a business by something,
whatever.
And that's a totally different game.
So
okay,
at that moment I'm thinking this is total misery.
I want to wake up every day and enjoy my life to have more energy being given to
me then taken away.
And in that moment I realized the game I'm playing isn't money.
It's not success,
it's brain chemistry.
And if the game that I'm playing is brain chemistry,
which I'll say another way,
deep and lasting fulfillment,
the thing that as a human makes us feel good.
The thing that we're all secret deep down,
no matter what you tell people,
you're chasing the thing,
you're actually chasing us.
Fulfillment.
You want to feel good about who you are.
You want to feel good about your contributions.
You want to feel good about meaning and purpose in your life.
So those are the things ultimately that people are chasing.
They think that money is going to give that to them and that they're wrong.
And that's how they keep getting caught off guard.
Now the reason that money is this trap that everyone can tell you as a trap and
yet it will still capture you is because money is real and it's really powerful
and the things that money lets you do in your life is almost unimaginable until
you have money.
And I see now what I'm doing.
Finally now having real liquid assets that are significant.
You can guys think for one second right now.
Imagine closing your eyes and thinking about that thing you most want,
the thing you want to build.
It's something beautiful.
It's something you want to leave your humanity.
I will just assume it isn't dumb shit like a car,
right?
It's really something.
It's something you want to build and give and it's going to be,
I don't think in legacy,
but like I get the sentiment.
It's going to be your legacy.
It's going to be that thing that outlasts you or helps other people or offers
jobs or build something that we all want.
The only thing stopping you from doing it,
you're going to say it's time,
but it's not time.
It's money and that's how money gets people.
Because once you know what you want to build with it,
then it's really powerful.
But if you're chasing money in and of itself,
you'll burn out.
I promise you won't enjoy your life because you're not thinking about that end
result.
So for the first,
so anyway,
at the height of all that,
okay,
making money,
wealthy on paper,
totally miserable.
I go into my partners and I say,
here's your equity back.
So literally me essentially sliding $2 million back across the table.
Thank you.
I'm quitting.
I can't do this anymore.
I'm not willing to keep chasing money.
I want to feel alive.
That was the statement I kept saying,
I want to go do a do something that you know,
brings me that sense of fulfillment and this isn't it.
And they said,
look,
come out to dinner with us.
They were taken aback,
very surprised.
We just gave them back $2 million,
gain back $2 million in quit.
And you know,
it was like,
this is goodbye.
And so it was super abrupt.
They said,
come out to dinner with us and I go out and they said,
we could do this without you,
but we don't want to.
And that phrase change the course of my life because what it allowed me to do
was connect to something other than the money.
And so for the first time,
but that point,
I mean we were six or seven years into the company of literally just around the
clock,
around the clock,
to give you an idea of how hardcore I was and how I had worked my way into
equity starting as a copywriter.
I rented an apartment that I timed so I could make sure that if my business
partners,
which remember at that time I was just our copywriter,
if they were to ever call me at two in the morning on a Saturday,
that I would be to their house in less than 10 minutes.
So I timed,
I would,
my wife would find an apartment she liked and then we would drive first to one
partner,
then back then to the other partner and see if both of them were less than seven
minutes is what I was aiming for.
And that was how we picked our apartment.
So that's how die hard I was.
Now they had made the same offer to everybody basically in the company they
would say,
we don't look for employees,
we settled for employees,
but we're always looking for partners.
And so I had really taken them up on that and that's how sort of all in I was.
So now after doing that for so many years and realizing it didn't bring me the
fulfillment that I wanted,
my wife having to pull me aside and saying,
you're damaging our relationship because you work so much.
My response was,
and I want balance in my life because I don't believe in balance.
And if you guys have ever seen my content,
you'll never hear me preach about balance or patients.
None of that.
Cause I have none of it.
Okay.
What I'm talking about is you one,
understand that passion is a process.
So there's,
there's no passion lurking within you right now.
There are areas of interest.
Your job is to experience a whole bunch of stuff.
Find those areas of interest.
So,
and then build them out.
Right?
Correct.
And then I can talk about that later,
but just to finish the story of how I ended up in nutrition.
So when they say we could do this without you,
but we don't want to,
I realized,
Whoa,
like that I needed that to connect to you as people.
As you know,
we talked a lot about this brotherhood.
We had a brotherhood and that brotherhood I realized over the years had become
incredibly valuable to me.
And it was a huge part of what helped me change as a human being was being
connected to other people who thought like I thought who would do something as
crazy as,
you know,
get an apartment in time it and all that.
Cause they had a goal and they were working towards her goals and like we just
talked the same language.
And so hearing that again and I was like,
okay,
I can get behind that,
but if we're going to work together,
there was just a few things that have to be true.
From my perspective,
maybe it's not the same for you,
but for me,
here's what it would have to be.
It would have to be a company predicated on value creation.
It would have to be something that we're passionate about.
We'd have to be building community and we would need to be really ourselves who
we truly are,
which was all a reaction to what we've been doing in the technology company,
which was all,
by the way,
I can't believe I'm giving this talk in Google.
I was learning Google ad words like that was my life.
And so there was,
it wasn't like communicating with another human being.
I was in like the bidding system and all of that.
And what are my competitors doing and how does that impact like my bidding?
And you know,
I mean this is like in what,
2005 2006 and so I didn't have a sense of connection to the consumer.
And so I really wanted to connect with them.
I wanted to build like,
um,
a community.
And so by the time we end up launching the company,
this is now 2009,
2010 Facebook is coming along.
Everybody's starting to think about as individuals,
how do we connect?
And then I started thinking about how do we connect as consumers too or as the
company to the consumer and thinking really what social media is.
It's just a megaphone and it's going to give people the opportunity to say
something about your company within minutes of an interaction with your company
to a global audience.
And so I was like,
if you guys can get excited about that,
and I'm quoting Kevin Kelly's thousand true fans and all that,
because in my desperation I've been reading about stuff just trying to figure
out what's another way to do this.
And so they said,
you know,
we actually feel the same.
We want to do something that's passion-based predicated on value,
allow us to build community.
They loved it all.
And so for three very different reasons,
we ended up on nutrition.
I grew up in a morbidly obese family.
So for me it was,
I needed to have a mission that was so big and so compelling that it gave me
energy that I could show up everyday and fight for people that I could think
about.
And there an awesome quote often attributed to Mother Teresa that says nobody
will act for the many,
but people will act for the one.
So if there's someone you can picture someone you know,
someone you love,
like you'll go to battle for them.
So I knew I'll show up everyday and fight for my mom and my sister and I know
that they're going to die too early if we can't figure out how to solve this
problem of making food that people want to eat,
tastes good.
And so that became the mission of the company was to end metabolic disease and
to do it by making food that people can choose based on taste and it happens to
be good for them.
Interesting.
And so,
so this process and you've finished school,
you copywriter,
you've kind of grown through the ranks and now it's pivot into nutrition
company.
So then how do we go from nutrition to impact theory?
Yes.
Yeah.
We have about storytelling and empowerment.
So if you know the classic Hero's journey,
then this is at the end of the Joseph Campbell's classic Hero's journey.
The part that isn't often talked about is the hero returns home to bring the
message to others.
So whatever that journey just taught him,
he's going to come back now and he's going to help other people with that.
And while I don't consider myself a teacher returning the film is very much me
returning home.
Right?
It's where I started.
It's my first love,
it's my deepest passion.
It's um,
and it is all of those things because of its ability to impact people.
So the irony is I wasn't trying to return to film.
What I was trying to do is pull people out of the Matrix.
So movies have,
I think in movies they've always just spoken to me maybe more than most.
And the movie,
the Matrix came out March 31st,
1999,
uh,
just had its anniversary.
It's 19 year anniversary.
And I remember going to a preview screening of that movie because I'm a comic
nerd and I was at a comic convention.
They were handing out tickets and when they're walking in to the opening scene
basically,
and the agents show up and the cop goes,
don't worry,
we can handle one little girl and agent Smith Goes,
no lieutenant,
your men are already dead.
And then they cut to trinity.
She jumps into the air,
freezes in that theater that I saw that in,
everyone screamed in unison and started clapping.
Now I had never experienced something like that ever in a movie before,
the spontaneous eruption of the entire audience in the middle of something that
wasn't like a scream or yell.
It was like celebratory.
They couldn't believe what they were seeing.
And then ultimately is the movie plays out.
It's a movie about belief.
And it was coming at a time in my life where the only thing I believed was that
I was a talentless hack and then I had no idea how to make my life come true.
So seeing this metaphor for belief and that what Neil really has to figure out
as that he's the one and that first for him to finally come to believe in
himself enough that he is the one someone has to tell him he's not the one.
And so he's got to go on that whole journey and he's got to try the impossible.
And it's got to be willing to face failure.
And the fact that it works is because nobody was ever before him willing to face
the failure.
And so because he's willing to face the failure,
and if you remember the movie,
he fails,
he dies,
but it's only in remembering,
wait a second,
these are just rules and I can break the rules that he then comes back and
realizes once he understands the rules,
once he believes in himself enough,
then he can do all this incredible stuff.
And I don't think we actually live in the matrix.
And if we do,
I don't think that it really matters.
But as a metaphor,
I think it's the perfect metaphor for the human experience because what you
believe about yourself will entirely dictate what you do with your life.
Okay,
now let that hang in the air now as that's hanging in the air.
Let me tell you a story.
I started big brothering when I was 18 years old for a kid in the inner cities.
One kid named Ms. Sean Jackson.
Sean,
I didn't know this at the time,
but he was in an abusive household.
He had been adopted and his mother was just brutal and he always wanted to spend
time with me.
And so when I first,
at first it was just supposed to be an eight week program,
I was going to go in and help him with his homework.
At six weeks,
they tell you,
hey,
make sure you warn them that you're only coming for two more weeks.
I warn him,
he goes,
nuclear,
unlike anything I've ever seen in my life.
Freaking out,
crying,
fighting with other kids.
I mean,
just like a whirling dervish,
she was pure insanity.
Finally get them over.
And I said,
is this because I said,
I'm only coming for two more weeks?
He says,
yes.
I say,
all right,
look,
I'll make you a promise if you'll settle down and do your homework.
Because he was always hard to wrangle.
If you'll settle down and do your homework as long as I live in Los,
I'll tutor you deal deal.
That ends up being an eight and a half year relationship that sees me helping.
I become the guardian of the court when he gets taken away from his abusive
stepmother or adoptive mother.
And I remember thinking,
this kid's amazing,
like he's so interesting and he's so interested in just like theirs.
It's just,
he's amazing.
But he once said to me the phrase,
I already been had that and I said to him,
you already been had that.
And he was like,
yeah,
I already been had that.
And I was like,
you already been had that.
And in that moment I realized he actually thought that's how you said it.
And so he goes,
well,
that's how my teacher says it.
And I was like,
oh my God.
And so here I am,
19 years old and this crashing realization hits me that because of where he's
born,
his options have just been limited.
Then if you ask him what he wants to do with his life,
his dreams are some small,
he's got no big dreams.
So I'm like,
wow,
strike two.
And then of course data now has come out just in treasure troves about how much
your zip code is going to determine your future success.
But I was living at,
I was seeing it happen before my eyes and then flash forward in quest
manufacturing and manufacturing,
you're in inner cities because that's where the zoning happens so that you can
actually get the kinds of things that I'm,
the kind of square footage that you need.
And so now I've got a thousand employees that all grew up like Rashawn and a
thousand people with small dreams.
And I started as a,
in the interviewing process because in the beginning everyone interviewed with
me,
whether you were the,
you know,
a chief sales officer or you were the janitor,
you've interviewed with me.
And so I just,
I saw thousands,
I've probably interviewed,
oh man.
Probably close to 3000 people at this point.
It was just crazy.
And every one of them I would ask the magic genie question.
Magic Genie.
He's about to show up.
They're going to grant you one wish and one wish only can't wish for something
for yourself.
So you can't,
or sorry,
you can't wish for something for somebody else to cure cancer brings somebody
back from the dead.
Whatever it's gotta be for you.
What do you wish for every single person,
every single person said the same thing.
Any guesses what they said?
That would have been so smart.
I did tell him they couldn't wish for more wishes,
so I didn't get that one.
They never would've thought to do that though.
So not a single person ever said that first.
I sent a job.
Okay,
fair enough.
Right.
You're here for an interview.
You think that's what I want to hear.
You think it's a trick question.
So then I would say,
I get why you said that.
That's not really what you want.
Is it?
No,
ha ha.
It's not,
okay,
what do you really want?
Money.
Okay,
fantastic.
How much money?
I never got any answer other than one.
And the answer was $1 million every time.
And you could wish for anything,
anything over and over and over you could ask for $1 trillion and you asked for
a million and it just,
it actually started to scare me.
Now that's a really long story,
but you need to understand like how deeply that embedded itself,
you've got Rashawn and me feeling like I totally failed to help him avoid what I
could see was going to be his future.
And then you have a thousand Russians and now I feel responsible to help change
their belief system.
And I believe if I can change their belief system,
I can change the course of their life.
And so we start in the same quest university and I tell people,
making the protein bars is just your tuition.
What you're really here to do is figuring out what you want to do with your life
and then get the skills that you would need to go and further yourself down that
path.
And I realize there's 25 things that I had done.
The my mind that if they did their minds,
they would truly have a growth mindset.
So I write these,
the impact theory,
belief system out.
It's the 25 things anyone needs to believe and do in order to be able to
manifest their dreams,
to actually make them come true.
And then I started the interview show and all that.
And then as I go through this and realize that the vast majority of these people
do not respond to the message,
right?
So think about how many people really respond when you just give them the direct
answer.
This is how you do what I've done.
Most people,
they don't listen.
It's not entertaining enough,
right?
So they just ignore it.
Like I'll just tell you right now,
the secrets of the universe,
anything you've ever wanted to know,
they've already been written in a book.
You literally don't need anything else.
It's already written.
If you were willing to go out,
read,
research,
put in the work,
practice tests,
it's already all there.
What people really want is entertainment.
A story a hundred percent.
So if you look at,
so I'm,
I'm a big believer,
don't try to change behavior.
Try to leverage it.
So if you said,
Tom,
you have to change the world,
would you rather leverage people's reading behavior or would you rather leverage
their viewing behavior?
The answer to me is very simple.
I'd rather control Netflix then the library of Congress if I want to make real
change.
So because one is just more on the surface,
just more entertaining,
it's passive,
right?
You have to work as hard,
you know,
flip pages you don't have to face.
Like for me,
I always had to face the inadequacy of how slowly I read.
Um,
whereas movies,
it was,
it was a truly emotive emotional experience.
So when I started looking at,
okay,
how do I,
you really no bullshit,
how do I change the lives of these thousand people or the hundreds of millions
of people that they represent?
How do I actually get them to adopt a belief system?
The answer is narrative.
Joseph Campbell,
and uh,
you know,
speaking of which,
um,
I love what you said about you cannot change human behavior.
You can,
we leverage it turned down right here and um,
you know,
do you go back to camp boy?
He said something that was a super profound as well.
He said,
you know,
if you want to change the world,
you have to change the metaphor.
And I think that's what you guys are attempting to do with like your structure,
your programs and your interviews and um,
to kind of take this back towards empowerment.
You know,
and you and I discuss this a little bit before we got on stage,
but you know,
I graduated in 2010 at the height of the recession.
So a very similar situation where,
you know,
there are no jobs.
It's frustrating.
You know,
I'm,
I'm angry,
I'm upset.
I can't rely on my parents cause they're in a worse situation than I am.
And you kind of,
you know,
descend into this pit of hell where it's you're angry,
frustrated,
all of these things.
And my question to you is like,
I wonder as well if like before you can take the empowerment,
but before you can own up and say,
actually I've got this,
I can do this.
If you have to go through those trials and tribulations before he can come back
up,
I don't think you have to.
But I think that most people will need that to be the thing that they find
themselves so profoundly unhappy that now they're moving in the opposite
direction.
It's emotional rock bottom.
Exactly.
So it's not a necessary component.
I think there are people that do it without it,
but I think that oftentimes the people that bounce back the farthest in the
other direction are the ones that hit hardest.
And um,
in some of your shows and,
um,
your,
our conversation,
we've talked about this idea that it's all your fault.
And at first glance it sounds very,
you mean,
right?
Like everything that happens is your fault.
But I think behind it there's like this nugget of wisdom where if,
if you can train yourself to keep things within your realm of control,
you'll always make the best of a situation.
You know,
everyone,
I was really young and I fell off my bike.
I wasn't wearing my knee pads,
you know,
I was upset and I was sad and you know,
my dad's first reply was what,
who told you about with any pads?
Like you were in control of that situation and it sucks at first to hear that.
But in the long run it's sort of built this resilience and this capacity to keep
things within your realm of control.
Now,
um,
to,
to bring this back to a question is,
you know,
Dr. Jordan Peterson would argue that if something,
when something goes wrong,
you start by like looking externally and seeing like,
okay,
what was actually responsible for and what happened outside of my domain of
control.
Whereas I think perhaps you and I would agree that maybe it's your start
internally,
okay,
how was are responsible for this,
you know,
was there anything I could have done differently?
And only then look outwards.
Would you agree?
Yes.
Yeah.
I think that the,
the reality is that I don't care about what the reality is that's,
that's like the truth.
And this is where I think people get really hung up with my message is you're
not experiencing life as it actually is.
Okay.
You're experiencing life through three pounds,
a mush.
That is a tri layer brain that is first trying to keep you alive,
right?
So your most based instincts in what they call the lizard brain.
Then you've got the Mammalian brain layered on top that's designed to give you
the emotions that you need to move in a specific direction with a lot of
authority and a lot of intent.
And then the thing that makes you uniquely human,
the Neo Cortex,
which allows you to ignore essentially those baser instincts.
But if you know something like the deep limbic system is when it's inflamed,
it processes data as being more negative.
So to give you an idea,
this is one of the most fascinating things about the brain.
As Shakespeare noted,
there is nothing good or bad,
but thinking makes it so there's nothing good or right.
There's just stimulus and then there's a response,
but the right.
But people think that it is objectively a certain way.
So now because they think it is an object objectively a certain way,
they feel they are supposed to react based on those emotions that are getting
kicked up in their mind.
What I'm saying is absolutely not.
Those emotions may not serve you.
They're certainly not aimed at moving your towards your goal.
They're jobs that keep you alive,
plain and simple.
So that's not necessarily very helpful in a modern context.
So if you want to always be moving towards your goal,
you want to be optimized,
you've got to learn to get control of your emotions.
You've got to learn to understand,
to tell yourself a narrative that isn't predicated on necessarily identifying
what is objectively true.
Because I don't think that we experienced the world that way.
It's identifying what's going to work to get me to my goal.
And that to me,
like my whole thing is goal first.
Everything else works backwards from that.
I start here from the like the grand strategy,
like identifying it and then building the steps backwards to reverse engineering
essentially.
Correct.
So the reason I say everything is my fault and that I use those words is it's a
litmus test.
If you're still having an emotional reaction to the word fault and you feel
compelled to argue with me because you think that I'm victim shaming,
like it just,
it tells me immediately where you are and your own journey,
right?
Like if you're going to waste time getting lost on the words you don't like
instead of going,
is there a part of this message that's usable for me?
Yes or no,
then it's a filtering mechanism.
People that haven't gotten past that first layer that they,
they,
they first have to address that.
Like whether or not they want to be goal oriented or,
yeah,
I definitely,
and something,
you know,
like I speak with,
the college students,
you know,
there's tours or intern programs and what's most fascinating to me is that in
order,
the thing that really try to convey to them is like,
look,
whatever happens there can be some good from or some benefit derived from it.
If you choose to look for that,
you know,
for that angle.
You know,
I'm always reminded of the stoics story of I think,
uh,
I forgot the philosopher's name at the moment,
but he was involved in a shipwreck and his friends immediately went to console
him to say like,
oh,
what a shame.
You know,
we're so sorry that you lost all these things.
And his reply was essentially like lost.
Like,
I'm free now.
I'm not held down by all of my possessions.
This is a fan.
This is fantastic news.
And so I think that that's where
a lot of our peers kind of get lost in,
is that the lack of realization that anything hasn't benefit,
if you can look at it that way.
Okay.
And I'll give you something else.
And this is something that I'm working on.
And so bear with me as I stumble through this,
this is one of the most important things for anybody to realize and anybody that
goes to,
um,
to that like the world is working against me.
Like that's their default answer.
What they have not yet figured out is that skills have utility and skills have
utility.
There's something in the way that we educate that leads people to believe that
skills are this temporary thing that's merely meant to help you pass the test,
to get the grade,
to get moved.
The next thing,
and we've lost an understanding certainly outside of engineering that is skill
has utility.
And what I mean by that is I believe the very purpose of life,
the whole reason that we're all here is to close your eyes.
Imagine a world the world that you want to become reality.
Open your eyes,
go acquire the skills that you will need to actually build that world and
barking your hero's journey.
Right?
And it's acquiring those skills no longer is a metaphor.
You're actually getting skills that allow you to do things and so people
understand skills in that context when they're an engineer because they know,
well,
if I know this programming language,
then I can actually write code that can be executed in this way.
An architect,
if I learn engineering principles,
I can build buildings that aren't going to fall down.
Right.
They understand that,
but like once you get into the humanities,
people no longer think about,
oh,
skills have utility.
Like they actually do something.
Like if I'm a teacher I should really probably learn about the developmental
cycle of children.
Why?
Because I need to control them.
If I can get them quiet,
paying attention in an optimal state for information,
then I can make them better students.
That's the utility.
Because of the things that I'm learning about how to get them to be quiet and
where I want them and all that.
I can get them in their seats.
I can get them paying attention,
prime them.
Like maybe what I have to learn about is the correlation between exercise and
cognitive optimization,
like whatever it is,
but like learning those skills.
If you get really good at that means your students will walk out of your
classroom better,
prepared,
better grades,
more knowledge go on to do better,
right?
Like they found in the Stanford marshmallow test.
The single most correlated factor of success is the ability to delay
gratification.
Well,
now imagine you're a teacher and you learn to teach kids how to delay
gratification.
That may be the single most important thing those kids will ever learn.
And because you learned that skill,
now that still has massive utility,
but people don't approach the world that way.
They're always looking for what's the broken system?
And I'm saying,
forget about that.
Figure out how to fix a system that fine,
but don't waste your energy trying to figure out what's broken in the system
until you know how to fix a system.
But most people don't.
They want to learn how to squawk.
They want to go,
I know it's broken.
Anybody can give you that really cool speech about how the current education
system was designed to create factory workers.
Okay,
we all know it.
But as anybody fixing the system,
no.
And it's not going to get fixed until somebody goes.
I have to learn the very nature of fixing systems.
That's the skill I have to acquire.
And I know what its utility is and then the expected outcome in the real world.
So when I hear people where their reaction is to bitch about a problem,
like let's you and I were talking,
you being Hispanic is working against you,
Jason,
you being an African American,
it's working against you.
Like you're going to have to go uphill,
but now what?
You're going to sit and complain about it because it won't help you.
Right?
So if you have a goal,
it's like it does suck that women have to work harder to get to the same place
that has a white male in America that I have get to.
But if it is true,
if we're all going to accept that it's true,
we can all sit there and go,
we need to focus on the system's fair enough.
And I'm glad that some people do that.
The other option though is to say,
well,
I completely control me.
And the one thing I will tell any human being alive right now,
there is always room for the best.
And once your able through your skills that have utility to move somebody else
closer to their goal,
you will become a hot commodity no matter what.
No matter what.
Okay,
think about the scientist.
What were the scientists after World War II?
Right before they were scientists.
For us,
they were Nazis,
but we were way happy to let go of that because they had crazy skills that we
needed,
right?
So really what it comes down to is what are your skills like if you've got
skills that can be used to build something beautiful,
to do something wonderful to the world,
to help people move towards their goals,
that will excite the masses because they,
they want that thing that you're going to create that it's going to improve
people's lives.
But only thing that mattered in all of that was you got really good at
something.
And somewhere along the way we lost that.
The punchline is no matter what you do to the system,
you know,
you as an individual need to get extraordinary at something.
And so my encouragement to people is go get extraordinary.
Like don't worry about whether the system is broken or not.
We built quest,
$1 billion company,
and in less than five years coming out of the great recession so more,
what was it in the Great Depression,
more millionaires were created in the great depression than any other time in
history.
It's like it just comes down to somebody goes,
honestly,
this is how I react.
This is,
some is too big and complicated.
I'm too afraid to try to get caught up in fixing that.
I'm too big of a chicken there.
I just said it.
I'm too big of a chicken to deal with that,
but I can deal with myself.
I can go get extraordinary,
right.
So focus on that.
Go get extraordinary.
Go become the best of whatever it is you want to be,
but go become the best of it and see how the world opens to you.
Okay.
I love it.
And it also like it's much more difficult than,
and I would argue noble to work on yourself as opposed to,
you know,
bitching or complaining about an esoteric system which is very loosely defined a
parent who you're speaking with.
And um,
I think that's where,
that's where we're at and that's how I think we can empower individuals to
become the best versions of themselves.
Cause then in doing that they all their communities,
their cities and hopefully the world.
Totally agree.
Awesome.
Tom,
we have a lot more to talk about in a fortunate,
we're very limited on time.
So I want to open up to questions from the audience,
Mr. Excellent.
Just a question just about
there.
You went to Mike.
Boom,
look at that check check.
All right,
perfect.
My Derek Carr impersonation.
Ah,
so this question actually just kind of popped into my head while you were
talking.
Cause I totally as fan boyish as this sounds.
I'm just put it out there like low 1000% agree with everything you've said.
And then I thought about when you said,
um,
just go be extraordinary.
And I'm curious to myself,
because I also agree with the idea that human beings can be extraordinary at
literally anything and all things that we haven't even thought of yet.
So when you set out on your quest to become extraordinary,
and when you sat on on your quest to become extraordinary,
was it just let me become extraordinary in general?
Or did you actually focus on,
I'm going to become extraordinary at this?
And final question,
what do you consider yourself to be extraordinary yet
awesome.
So I don't think there is extraordinary in general.
And my biggest lament,
my biggest heartbreak is that every entrepreneur or to a person without
exception will come to me and say,
okay,
Hey,
I've got this vision.
I've got my mission's crystal clear,
my business plan ready to rock.
And as you begin to push and poke,
you'll realize they have no clarity whatsoever.
And the best analogy is someone woke,
and this is how the entrepreneur's approach me.
I want to win a gold metal.
And they think the fact that they want to win a gold medal is clarity,
man.
That they've got it on lock and I'm like,
awesome.
In the Olympics.
Yes.
Okay,
cool.
Summer or Winter Games?
Summer.
Okay.
Fantastic.
Tennis,
no swimming.
Yes.
Okay,
great.
Uh,
the medley,
the backstroke,
like until you get down to the very specific event in which you want to win that
gold medal,
you don't know how to train right then.
That's where it becomes an issue,
right?
So somebody who wants to be extraordinary in general,
like how do you train?
What does that mean?
So I need to know exactly what you want to do.
So for me,
the thing that I want,
and I won't say that I'm yet extraordinary in anything,
and that's a very stoic stance and I hopefully everybody takes it.
Like the more you learn,
the more you realize you have to learn.
So the thing that I'm committed to becoming extraordinary at is telling stories
that change people at the belief system level.
So that's my goal,
right?
Where I'm just entertaining them.
They don't know that anything else is happening.
But that a generation or two generations from now,
nobody would think to tell their kids anything other than everything is your
fault to me.
Come on like you know better.
Like at the end of the day,
your life is a reflection of your choices and they won't even remember that.
It was a Jimminy cricket style character that told Pinocchio that in a movie
that I made,
they just have the words to repeat.
It's that belief system.
It's baked in,
right?
It's part of the cultural subconscious.
We're all talking about it.
We all respond to each other that way,
so that when somebody is woe is meaning,
we don't feed into that.
When somebody is saying,
oh,
this system is broken,
we immediately go,
Rad.
What do we do about it?
How do we fix it?
What skill do we need to go repair it?
But that's not the public discourse right now,
right?
The public discourse right now is your victim shaming.
No,
I'm not.
I don't want them to be a victim.
You're going to be victimized in your life of this.
I promise you.
But you decide whether or not you're a victim,
which is a state of being.
So all of those things right now are hotly contested.
What I want to do through entertainment is just make it patently obvious how we
should all be thinking,
acting to make our dreams come true.
So that's the thing.
I want to be extraordinary.
And then I think there was one more part to that question.
So the question was loaded,
so it was a,
could you be,
oh well actually no,
you answered both because it,
it's two part question.
What did you set out to be extraordinary at?
What do you consider yourself extraordinary yet?
And then what are your comments on just being extraordinary,
seeking to be extraordinary in general.
Okay.
I,
when I think about like what is the meaning of life?
I really believe nature made a choice with every creature it creates and it
essentially as a bifurcated path.
Number one is I'm going to preload you with all the algorithms.
We call them intuition or your instincts.
And so you come with instincts and like a horse fall when it comes out,
it can walk.
It can run,
it can jump,
it can feed a human baby.
On the other hand,
when it's born is a lump of flesh.
It poos in its own diapers.
You could lay it next to a bottle and it would still starve to death.
Like we are completely dependent because what we want to do is actually finish
the maturing of the brain on the outside in the stimulus to which we need to
become adapted.
So the reason that humans have become the ultimate apex Predator,
unlike anything this world has ever seen before ever,
is our ability to adapt.
Now,
if you believe that adaptation is the absolute core of what makes us great is
our defining characteristic,
then it becomes a question of,
well how does nature make sure that we do what nature wants us to do?
So if nature wants us to adapt,
it's going to make it pleasurable.
So when you think about what a human is really want,
I think it's a deep and lasting sense of fulfillment.
Okay?
It's the,
it's the happiness that lasts.
It's the non transient bowl of ice cream style happiness and it's the,
I just saved somebody from a burning building.
It's the,
I've helped these children's lives are going to go and be better.
It's things like that to make you feel good about who you are as a human being
and what your contributions are.
That actually comes from suffering.
It comes from working hard.
It comes from putting in that effort because that's what you have to do to
adapt.
You adapt to a stressor.
You adapt to paying,
you adapt to difficulty.
You get stronger under heavier and heavier weight,
right?
That's how it works.
That's just the the call and answer of nature.
So that process is intensely pleasurable in the sense of fulfillment.
So going out and doing the hard things to see how much of your potential you can
actuate.
Pursuing greatness in a very specific direction is I believe the only thing that
will make people happy.
So when I look at depression,
anxiety,
all on the rise,
all rampant people feeling lost,
not knowing what they want to do,
where they want to be.
The answer is decide you're going to be extraordinary at something because it
gives you more energy than it takes.
And there's a whole process and not going to go into it now,
but get that thing in your life and then go after it with everything you have
with total disregard for balance that you pour yourself into it in a way you
give yourself over to it.
And I think we have one more bifurcation.
You've got the family which provides a similar sense of deep fulfillment and I
think that's a perfectly valid choice.
And if you don't hear the incongruent nature with what I'm saying,
I'm not saying it very well,
but those are the two paths at IC.
Humans go on,
people that are parents,
they really,
the kid was born,
changed my life perspective.
Totally done,
right?
Like you know the,
the talk and how it feels.
And then on this side you've got an equal lack of balance.
All in totally committed.
Do or die,
I would give myself over to this thing that I'm building.
Right?
And that's where I'm at.
I've chosen not to have kids,
not the path I'm on,
but I've given myself over in a similar way and I get a similar sense of deep
fulfillment.
Great.
Thank you.
For sure.
Um,
in terms of adopting this growth mindset,
or like just developing yourself as an individual,
how big of a role when you say is,
um,
managing your relationships and how important is it that the people around you
adopt more or less the same mindset or support this mindset you're adopting?
So you're now poking me and my soft underbelly,
which I appreciate you asking the hard questions.
Um,
as a CEO,
it is ridiculously important to make sure that your team is on this page,
that they're totally bought in,
that they're thinking the same way and acting the same way.
Otherwise your culture begins to fragment and get toxic.
Um,
as a person just out in the world,
it's amazing to surround yourself with other people that think like that because
you're going to reinforce it and you,
and that's such a beautiful thing to have in your life and they're going to push
you and escalate you to be better.
Um,
but also as an individual,
no one should be able to stop you.
Right?
And so whether you're working in a toxic environment or not,
and everybody else acts like a dumb ass.
Like when people come to me and they write in and say,
Hey,
I'm working in an environment because I'm a huge believer.
If you guys haven't read Ray Dalio is principles read.
It's incredible.
But every time I recommend it to somebody that works in a company where I
imagine the culture for one person to change to be so hard,
I do have little pangs of guilt.
But here's the truth.
You could put me in in any organization in the world and the strategy that I
would adopt if I wanted to move up and I wanted to change the culture would be
to become useful to other people with no need to get the credit because secretly
I know deep down inside when people steal from you,
they know they're stealing from you,
not that they're going to feel guilt.
I don't need them to feel guilt.
I want them to be terrified of losing proximity to me,
which now all of a sudden means people begin to orbit around me because I'm
helping their life.
Then all of a sudden it's just,
oh why is everybody orbiting around him?
Like they're always turning to him and you ever notice like everybody knows if I
took whoever your is running a meeting and I took them out,
suddenly there'll be a second person that all eyes will start going to and that
person is the unofficial leader of the group.
Right.
And I would immediately as fast as I could by giving value to other people by
not caring about getting any credit for my own ideas.
But pumping out ideas that are wrapped more rapid pace by being extraordinary,
by making sure that I'm better than this at everyone else by being more
prepared,
by putting in more work,
all of that,
that people would begin to rotate around me.
It's a longer strategy,
but in in that situation now you've got a lot of clout with people and so when
you say,
I don't do that,
I don't steal ideas,
all of a sudden then people would start to feel guilty about stealing ideas from
you.
You start to see a shift slowly over time,
so I won't over answer your question,
which I've already gotten real dangerous to.
I'll stop there,
but I'm really,
really fascinated about antagonistic group dynamics and how to change them by
being the unchangeable of just like having a true north about what your ethics
are and just always being true to it.
That's why I was wondering if you could talk a little bit about clarifying your
goals and what you're chasing and how much of that is just choosing something
and committing to it and going after it.
And how much of it is really a process of figuring out what you want and
chipping away at that end and getting very clear on it through some internal
process.
Here's the amazing part.
You've actually already answered the question.
So,
and most people only get one half.
So it really is both of what you just said.
You need to do the work first of being like,
what do I really want?
What?
And so now walk through the process that I alluded to a couple times.
So passion is not a lightning rod moment.
It is not something that's hiding inside of you.
It is a process.
You're an architect,
not an archaeologist.
Okay?
So what you're gonna do is you're going to go experience a whole lot of stuff.
And Kevin Kelly,
the founder of wired magazine,
talks about not prematurely optimizing.
And I think that that's so important.
So in life,
if you don't have a passion,
you want to go experience a lot of things with almost total disregard for what
that might be.
When you encounter something that you find interesting,
engage with it more as you engage with it.
See,
is this turning into a real fascination?
If it's turning into a real fascination,
then ask yourself a very simple question,
do I want to become the greatest in the world at this?
And if the answer is yes,
if the thought of that fills you with excitement,
winning that gold medal or designing that thing or whatever,
you think,
oh my God,
like that would be amazing.
And the thought of actually putting in that works kind of cool.
Like I want to develop that skill set.
Now you're going to go down the path of gaining mastery.
And I'm stealing this,
excuse me,
from a guy named cal Newport and a book called so good they can't ignore you.
And I think that passion is like love.
I don't believe that there's one sided love.
I think that's infatuation.
Love is where you're in a real relationship.
There's give and take.
There's vulnerability.
There's all the things that make real love,
this beautiful interplay of two brains that are actually in sync.
Like as in you can see it in an FMRI scanner.
It's really crazy.
Okay,
that's love.
Infatuation is the stage before that.
So you don't know if you have a passion for something until you're gaining
mastery.
You were sincerely pursuing becoming the best in the world at that.
And those skills have utility and as you put that utility to the test in service
of something bigger than yourself helping other people,
you will get energy from that.
As a social creature knowing I've worked my ass off for this,
Greeks have a name for,
it's called Techny.
I've worked my ass off for this set of skills and it actually helps other people
and it makes me feel good and I'm contributing.
And so that thing where it's like I show up every day and technically I'm at
work,
but I'm actually building something that's helping people.
And that makes me feel really good.
One,
it's hard and I'm pushing myself and I love it and it's interesting.
And then on the other hand,
it actually helps like,
and it's that dope interplay.
Now where people get stuck is,
we were just talking about this before we started the,
um,
the talk,
most people are standing in that room,
they've got a thousand things are interested in.
They can't bring themselves to shut any one of those doors.
And because they don't shut any one of those doors and never walked through the
one remaining door.
And so I always tell people,
your job is to shut doors.
Literally the word decide means to close.
It's like the what of break it up in Latin or to cut,
excuse me,
it means to cut,
to cut something out,
right?
So you're cutting out the 999 other options and going with just the one.
And if you have to do it at random and just shut blindly,
999 doors,
fine,
go through that one c is it a fascination or not?
And if it's not,
come back,
open a new one and move.
The only thing that's really going to ruin you as a person is indecision.
It's the only thing you should fear.
Well guys,
thanks so much for joining,
Tom.
Thank you for coming by.
Thanks for having me.
It was a pleasure and privilege.
Yeah.
[inaudible].